Hey youtubers it’s Charlie and these are
going to be my Korra Book 4 predictions. The
good news is that Mike and Bryan said that
pretty much every major character and storyline
gets dealt with by the end. As of right now
there isn’t an official release date but
plan for Summer next year until they say otherwise.
It will stream for free everywhere it is right
now. But let’s get going. Careful for spoilers
from the finale if you haven’t seen it yet.
I’ll wait just a sec...Okay, starting with
number 10 - There will be no Korra presence
at Comic Con next summer.
Mostly because they’ll probably release
it before then. The Second big reason is because
if they barely spent any time or energy marketing
it this year and they’ve already written
the cost of producing it off. They already
paid for all the episodes to be made. Why
bother spending the extra money to rent out
ballroom 20 and bring the cast out.
If you want to do a panel at comic con you
have to pay money and if you want a booth
on the floor it’s crazy expensive.
Mike and Bryan said during the comic con panel
this year for book 3 that they expected it
was their last time at San Diego Comic Con
for Korra.
They will be at New York Comic Con this fall.
That’s October 9th to 12th. I won’t be
there, but I will be doing videos for any
big stuff that happens.
Number 9 - Book 4 will be the last Avatar
Series, there will be no Movie but the Comics
will keep going
Mike and Bryan said that they were pretty
fried on the Avatar Universe after spending
the last 10 years of their life working on
it. They will continue to develop new shows,
probably animated shows. But they won’t
be Avatar related.
The big asterisk is nothing is every confirmed
in Hollywood. People quit stuff all the time
and then a dump truck of money rolls up and
all of a sudden it’s a thing again. So more
Avatar video is up to Nick. Which is unlikely.
But the comics will totally keep going, they’re
way easier to produce and they have a lot
more freedom with what they can do. So more
Last Airbender and Korra Stories via the comics.
Also there are video games coming right now.
Depending on the success of those, there will
be more games.
I know everyone wants an animated movie and
a billion more seasons. But Bryke basically
said on the podcast he did that he doesn’t
want to do that.
Which leads to Number 8 - The Book 4 Finale
will end in a way that allows the Avatar Cycle
to continue even if it’s not on screen
There is no way any of their writing or belief
systems have led me to believe that Korra
will be the Last Avatar ever. That whole idea
was a major plot point of the Book 3 finale.
Zaheer thought the world didn’t need the
Avatar anymore, but Tenzin clearly states
evidence as to why they need an Avatar more
than ever.
The Line will continue. We just don't’ know
if Korra will survive the finale or if we’ll
see her live to old age.
What I’d like to see whether or not they
choose to do it, is for the final scene to
be something close to Avatar Wan’s final
scene in Beginnings. Where Korra is dying
in old age in the middle of a battle or even
just at home with her family and we hear a
baby cry out as she fades away.
Just a way to imply that 1, the avatar cycle
is continuing and 2, there is still imbalance
in the world, everyone still needs an Avatar.
I would like to see a flashforward or at least
some acknowledgement that Korra got some of
the things she wanted in life.
I understand if they chose not to do that
in an explicit way. Sometimes that’s too
on the nose and it’s more effective to just
imply that the cycle will continue regardless
of what’s going on in the world.
Avatar is all about cycles. Harmonic Convergence,
Raava and Vaatu, the 100 year war and now
the collapse of the Earth Kingdom. Everything
gets repeated, so I’d at least like to see
an ending that fits with that thematically.
On to Number 7 - Jinora is going to follow
a more enlightened version of the path that
Aang and Korra went on.
I don’t think they’ll copy and paste Aang’s
character development on to her. But she is
a child burdened with the leadership of the
Air Nation, so you can’t help but point
to Aang. The difference is that she has his
level of spirituality with Korra’s gung
ho attitude. So it’s like she all of their
best qualities.
I think the series is positioning her to be
the next non-Avatar World Leader. Like she’ll
be the new Iroh and probably go on to lead
the white lotus along with the Air Nation
for the rest of her life.
Avatar Yangchen is the best example of a female
air master. So think of Jinora as living out
a life similar to that.
Number 6 - All the major characters will be
back
That includes Katara, Zuko, Toph, all off
the Team Aang characters that are still alive.
The major conflict is the revolution that
the Red Lotus is trying to start. Zaheer said
that it had started but as far as we know
that’s only in the Earth Kingdom.
I think they’ll continue to use the original
Last Airbender characters the same way they
used Zuko in book 3. As support for Team Korra.
Lots of unanswered questions about where Toph
and Azula have been since last we saw them.
Because Bryke said they tie everything up.
I think it at least means we’ll get an answer.
Maybe not the answer we want, but something
is better than nothing.
Number 5 - Korrasami will still be a thing
I know a lot of you ask me my thoughts on
korrasami. I love the two of them together
but I don’t think there’s anything sexual
going on. They just wanted Korra and Asami
to have a positive female friend that didn’t
have anything to do with boyfriends.
Yes they do share Mako in common, but he’s
the only one at this point that’s still
weird about it. With all that Korra has been
through I’m expecting Asami to stay and
help take care of her until she’s fully
healed.
During last airbender Aang had to heal the
avatar spirit by reconnecting with his past
lives in the spirit realm. I know they’ve
retconned a few things, because at the time
those episodes aired. Mike and Bryan hadn’t
incorporated the idea of Raava, Vaatu and
Avatar Wan into the series. So there were
only a handful of Avatar spirits he had to
visit.
Korra is still cut off from all her past lives.
But unless they change things again there’s
always Yangchen’s Festival. I know a few
of you have asked me about this on a couple
videos.
Which should make you guys excited for Number
4 - Korra will reconnect with her past lives
I know Mike and Bryan did an interview after
book 2 ended saying Korra would continue to
be cut off. But I think it’s possible they
could have just been talking about Book 3.
The Yangchen Festival method comes straight
from The Rift Part 2. That was written by
Mike and Bryan and published just last month.
So it’s way more current than their earlier
comments about Korra being cut off.
That happens all the time, where a creator
does an interview and teases something that
gets taken too literally.
What is Yangchen’s Festival? This is where
it gets more exciting. It’s an Air Nomad
festival started by Avatar Yangchen, the female
airbender I said Jinora is going to resemble.
Airbenders are back, which means they’ll
celebrate Yangchen’s festival again in book
4. Which gives Korra a backdoor for reconnecting
with her past lives.
Yangchen started the Festival as a way to
uphold a treaty with the ancient spirit of
Old General Iroh. Not Uncle Iroh, someone
who was way way older. the Festival continued
after her death as a way for the air nation
to honor her achievements.
They don’t really explain the physics of
how participating in the festival facilitates
the reconnection of past lives. But I take
them at their word.
If you’ve listened to the Book 2 dvd commentaries.
Sometimes Mike and Bryan fudge the logic of
situations. Like Jinora pulling Raava out
of Unavaatu. They didn’t get really granular
the opportunity to speak with Aang and the
other avatars again.
On to Number 3 - None of the Previous Villains
will be the problem of book 4
Zaheer won’t escape and be the big bad again,
Unalaq and Amon are dead but The Red Lotus
is still around. I don’t see them as being
the big bad though. I think the real villain
will just be chaos itself and the air nomads.
As Tenzin said, will just travel from nation
to nation and help make things zen again.
There’s also the x-factor of Varrick and
his high speed rail. I think part of healing
the world is bringing it closer together.
And the fastest way to do that is to create
high speed travel between cities. It’s like
the advent of the internet making the real
world smaller so to speak.
I can post a youtube video and instantly all
over the world anywhere there’s internet
people can watch it at the same moment.
So I think Jinora and the air nation will
be like the spiritual solution and Varrick
will be the practical solution. Plus, if he
can establish a monopoly on shipping he’ll
get even richer, which sounds like something
he would do. So he gets rich and gets to help
people. Although that part he probably doesn’t
care about so much.
Number 2 - Worldwide democracy will be a goal
I think the things that Souyin talked about
while they were still with the Metal Clan
will start to spread. Those ideas for equal
representation.
When you look at the governments of all the
bending tribes the Fire Nation and the Water
Tribe are still the only ones that have acting
monarchs. And technically Korra’s father
is more of an elected leader than the feudalistic
structure of the Fire Nation. They will be
the last holdouts.
Which is where Zuko’s daughter comes in.
As of right now the Fire Nation has been conspicuously
absent with the exception of Zuko’s grandson
Iroh. He’s a general in the United Forces.
So technically the Fire Nation didn’t contribute
any help in books 1 and 2, at least that we
saw.
So I think that part of the move toward balance
will be the fire nation royal family giving
a lot of it’s legislative power away like
the royal family in England.
In England the royal family is more of a figurehead
at this point and the day to day job of running
the country falls on the government.
And my number 1 prediction - Azula will also
be back
She hasn’t been confirmed dead, the last
time we saw her was in the Search Comic and
she was traveling with Team Avatar. She was
still totally nuts, but just like Toph. I
think we’ll at least get a flashback.
I fully expect all the notable characters
to be around when the series ends. Think about
it this way. You start with everyone together,
then circumstances draw them further and further
apart till new circumstances pull them back
together. It’s like you have a single Avatar
Book that binds the original series and Legend
of Korra together. As Korra’s story has
been told. you open the book and you have
last airbender people on one side of the page
and the new team korra people on the other
side.
Logically by the end of the story the book
has to be closed, bringing both the old characters
and the new ones together.
That’s the perfect situation, of course
the alternative is that all out mass hysteria
and war could bring everyone back together.
Azula could always sieze on the new revolution
to try and ursurp control of the fire nation.
She does have a claim to the throne.
At this point though, she’s a little bit
younger than Zuko, so she’d still be a very
formidable warrior.
Wouldn’t it be cool to see Old Katara and
Old Azula throw down. I’m not expecting
anything like that but it’s fun to fantasize
about.
But let me know what your predictions are
do you think that Toph and Azula will reappear
and do you think that Korra will reconnect
with her past lives?
So busy weekend. Korra is going away for a
little while and Doctor Who is coming. I will
be doing a Korra Q&A, hopefully I’ll have
that up tonight. There’s also a video I’m
working on based on a big interview Mike and
Bryan did, but that might take a few more
days to finish. I will be doing new Korra
next week.
I also think there are a few giveaways running
right now, I’m catching up. There is definitely
a weekly Doctor Who giveaway, so even if you
don’t like Doctor Who you should check out
those videos. I will be posting one shortly.
But Right now click here for my Korra Finale
video and click here for the Q&A, I’ll add
the annotation as soon as I post it.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tonight.
High Fives!